now my boy mouse got his beautiful
Ethiopian girl okay yeah chocolate yes
my other boy Justin's got his Eritrean
girl not Eritrea is the country that's
above Ethiopia they're both beautiful
women in that part you know obviously
she's not they're both black so thank
you them oh thank you but as is Maalik
and much more just like it so so now now
we're dancing a me and Malik Malik 27
we're having a dance-off we're right at
the bar at this club right near the W
we're being silly kidding I wish you
weren't dancing but everybody was I'm
the old guy having a dance of a monk
joking around fun but we're having a
[ __ ] silly time just to the show I'm
just having a good time being an idiot
now if this is going to you fighting
gets bad as I would fight you if I saw
you dancing should yeah now I'm noticing
that this guy these these men who I
reckon you know how I can pick out
nationalities right away oh yeah and
that's I've ever seen them yep there are
therefore African gentlemen and I happen
to clock a man I go those guys are
clearly from Ethiopia and they're
staring you down well there now remember
my boys with an Ethiopian gal oh I'm one
of them's drunk
and he starts kind of walking up to the
girls that were with and they're getting
kind of one guys getting kind of grin
out these guys because they've been
Americanized a little heavy and not so
good-looking and kind of shitty in
general now here's why now I'm rolling
with skinny fat build a fuel B yeah and
I'm rolling with I'm rolling with some
American black guys who aren't hearing a
peep now and yeah we're talking about
the other side of Africa by the way
probably ancestrally West African which
is different thing and now I got giant
Viking white guy I got I got Russian guy
and lady's American I got big Irish guy
my buddies larrikin these are Americans
okay you understand
although Lex is Russian oh so so now but
you know you know Albright Rhys insecure
and get super hot headed now situation
just small slow slow and the less
skilled correct right I am glad you said
it
booth who's the first gotta fight mostly
skelton you Ryan
the Chihuahua most incest Wawa's most
insecure the old scalawag Chihuahua
Ricky by the way my name is Rick
so thank you very much sorry man right I
mean everywhere I go Thanks I'm getting
screamed out in the whole foods for
God's sake in [ __ ] Utah I get to Park
City right like I walk in rags dude oh
my god
Jesus Christ there it is and I'm walking
I hear about the counter raves that's my
name so submarines the Chihuahua starts
to bark so I I and I yeah I like words I
like somebody knows how to use word yeah
so this guy is now all of a sudden music
stops and this guy looks right at my
bookmark and goes hey that's our sister
man that's our sister you shouldn't be
with our sister oh and I go what and he
goes man shut up you don't know if the
pho I go I go the [ __ ] you talk now I'm
numb and now they're getting their
posturing now Malik Malik literally you
could be his loss he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's like he's literally he's already
diffused three fights he could give a
[ __ ]
he's so such a goofball he's not even
noticing the areas there is hilarious oh
look at him lifting weights oh I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] him up for that is
that he's so high the way one of us a
silly goose all lives only to be a silly
good okay so now he's not even he's not
giving him anything and I'm like what
the [ __ ] that's this is so he has no
[ __ ] these Brian Brian this is how Brian
could diffuse to tell me you looked
everywhere I'm the captain now I didn't
say [ __ ] Brian just got what I would
have said coolly goes like this cool he
goes hey bro you know jaws and the guy
goes y-yes jaws in the movie no job they
have accents yeah they had the accents
but they spoke very valid names you got
goes yeah and he goes you're the girl
enjoy swimming in the water just having
to swim she's got no idea there's a
shark gonna pull him under I'm the clown
the shark I'm gonna pull you under it
was the greatest [ __ ] thing and he's
so big and and he's just like sitting
there looking up I'm the shakopee you're
the girl in charge swim think I gave him
the thumbs up in this bucket
both the oh oh
took a look and they're like ah this is
a bad would be a very bad it was so
[ __ ] great from the shore it was so
great great we came up on the street
it's 1:00 in the morning it's now what I
say the Virgin bond I said all oh my god
okay it's the pear base get in the hotel
now nothing good happens right now
nothing good happens on the street
nothing III heard and everybody like
like a [ __ ] collie another thing just
nice and good happen and then I came
back out that's for Ethiopian guys were
there oh and hey hey you went on the
captain a surround it and then just
around it guys
fat belly cuz they're not eating hey you
guys our first swim yeah you guys out
for a swim
how's the water is it choppy I slew them
I slew all of them us my friends the
shark and I'm the batter hoedown the old
squeal squeal I must suck you boys on I
do go around the squid I squeezed I
choked them my tentacle suck it no I
know that's not on the squid calm you
guys down right quick with my mouth the
old squid old please all right forearm a
circle 8 1 2 6 Wilshire Boulevard
Beverly Hills if you ever need me that's
why I train now listen to through your
fine talent that's where you find me I
was doing I was doing take that greco
take downs I'm so ready I can't give me
a little more time sure you want every
time you want don't be the take back for
all the time don't be disrespectful
because when I when I represent my
sensei Higa Machado yep Allen if you
want to make love you could judge it you
come on down bro but do me a favor you
come down to 8 1 2 6 Wilshire Boulevard
ok you come correct right I'm coming
correct I respect the hell out of him
yeah come correct and finish in front of
them huh
I need a little more time I'm gonna pin
you down now all your pants I'm funny
instructor know what yeah I need more
time piss on you know I don't want to
get [ __ ] drunk I'm gonna piss on your
friend UCO's no ho no Jim I'm gonna
train and I'm gonna take my jujitsu
supersuit seriously
and in 10 years you piece of [ __ ] it's
coming and it's gonna be surf and turf
but it's gonna be mostly turf it's gonna
notice to start cryin and now I'm gonna
surf you cuz you're gonna be on the turf
okay you understand me when I'm done
with you I'm gonna get on you like this
and I'm gonna surf you cuz you're gonna
be passed out and I'm gonna surf you so
I'm gonna get you on the turf and then
I'm gonna surf you dude and that's my I
hate to be shitty don't put your finger
near me about your head here in ten
years let's go to current events fine on
that note I'm gonna let's have a
grappling match when this lockdown is
over and I'm not gonna train at all
you versus I'm training nothing dude all
right dude trip but I don't I don't I
don't I haven't trained I haven't put on
Aggie or rash guard in six months well
that yeah but you're still training a
lot I want you a purple belt a blue belt
well I would love to roll with you but
you're strong guy and you're young and
athletic and you've trained a long time
right I'm scared I all done in forever
but I would love to we'll do it you'll
beat me up you'll beat me up are we
gonna go take downs from the from the
standing position like any jujitsu
competition that's ever existed careful
now right that's in high school and I
don't wrestle at all I have no refuge
that's on high school no dude yeah yeah
I'm saying you could just blast a double
after high school I'm a judoka guy okay
let's not and I am about hey let's not
Oh
let's before you after high school are
me up if you ever touch me he says he
was you know not my history American
team that's not true at all
I could never hide like I said I saw a
mountain lion lying so you're gonna
wrestle in college we know that I'm
gonna choke you so hard so you you are
gonna be surprised that your hands will
be a little more fuller than you expect
I believe that you can you'll probably
take me down because you do have the
experience in judo and all that like
where you like when I'm gonna wrap my
legs around you and you're gonna get a
cold oh you're gonna get a feel of my
grip and you're gonna go oh [ __ ] what
have I done and your nightmares will
come true you strong kid I'm gonna grab
your arm and yank it across then I'm
gonna triangle you too and I'm not gonna
give up when you tap in I'm gonna put
him asleep and I'm gonna get up and I'm
gonna I'm gonna probably teabag you
through my pant really did a foam in
your mouth
now now I'm I got some tricks up my
sleeve
I carry a small knife tiny knife I'm
gonna cut you up a little bit
mark you up your back and stuff like
this you got a nice skin I'm jealous of
it so I'm gonna carve you up you're
shredded I'm gonna shred you up even
more clothes in a Boston Market and my
elbows might open up to my up a couple
[ __ ] a couple streaks on your face
you elbow me and I'm gonna push you off
I'm gonna get up I'm gonna let kick you
so [ __ ] hard that's what I love
you're gonna you're literally gonna cry
this is like in front of other grunge TV
I guess you know see me jump over leg
kicks have you what will happen is
you'll go I have to jump over and I'll
catch the [ __ ] like a football player
getting depleted like a wide receiver
come across with your head open walk
into the ground and I will fall over
laughing well I want to promote this
I'll be the Dana White
it's me for 99 what are you lift a lot
you can move a lot of weight are you
very strong yeah I mean I'm not like him
but I for a guy my size I'm what are you
what do you deadlift hey what are you
deathless 5 20 oh my god what are you
dead left Brian not even does more not
even not even mine oh I don't need you
answer I know about military [ __ ] okay
Billy
I don't like your saying I'm just saying
cuz you're gonna make me I up your new
training boomer but I've been dreaming
boom boom boom boom I'm gonna embarrass
you in front of your sensei he's gonna
see this you know I can't get a black
belt next week what's the problem you
two on one dude boom boom sit down no
boomer no what's this
don't make me roll out now huh so make
me roll out and [ __ ] up the studio raw
this heel hook boomer boomer sit down
okay day okay boomer that's what I said
when I go in
two on one I was gonna fight on the way
here do you know that oh wow
this [ __ ] guy was driving his bike
and I he was coming a little citrate no
he's riding a bike a [ __ ] I could
tell by his face he was a [ __ ] I was
like you're riding a bike that's old you
probably stole your
[ __ ] Hera's all [ __ ] up guy yep
white guy about my age maybe a little
younger homeless no but a [ __ ] you
know just a general [ __ ] you go in
there and he's got he's got a he's my
age and he's got some ramen noodles and
a futon and he's got a [ __ ] mangy dog
he never walks always hold me you know
that guy he smells like mothballs all
the time
[ __ ] with man who knows what is
Venice now he's just a [ __ ] yeah one
of those guys everybody think homeless
and he [ __ ] is crossing the street
you say get a job no he's crossed the
street and I go well you're not even
crossing yet I'm gonna pull I'm gonna
I'm gonna cut off from yeah yeah
and yeah I knew he goes you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
sure and I stopped and I went I looked
at him and I went you want to start me
up [ __ ] you oh my [ __ ] now when I
suffered when I pop my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
I went [ __ ] you and I never do that cuz
he's crap I don't give a [ __ ] about that
guy crazy I don't know why but I got mad
at him I went [ __ ] you oooh I stopped
and looked at me and I looked at him and
I went do so why oh yeah anyway huh his
face tighten up in the cab man I kept
driving cuz I'm brave and then he I saw
him yell at me afterwards I was like
that way oh yeah gave me old bird and
I'd never do that either
I mean his Energy's like that in the car
okay what you're watching okay I'm good
you're good careful now okay
okay kids run a casual lazing about I
practice this now I know how bad you
want to talk about you doing it I'm
ignoring it and I don't want to talk I'm
just saying what I do is I keep my elbow
to the ground like that when I get a get
low fives for you know no fire traffic
for you um
no very very little I don't know how I'm
gonna get home can I stay with you Brian
yeah you can say whether you want to
roll I'm just gonna keep ignoring your
jujitsu I'm a Higgin I'm a Hagen Machado
student now I had a private with Hagen
Machado and my rear naked in my
guillotine sick how was the air pilot
let's knock this out how was your
private what why did you do a private he
gave Machado's a friend of mine where's
miss favorite comedian and he'll tell
you that okay I miss favorite comedian
okay it's my pleasure my friends never
sees me in your shows
man I'm friends with it's [ __ ] my old
biz being and I trained with Higa
Machado it's like I'm right am I the
toughest actually you know I think so
dude am I the toughest after you know I
I will say I said he can said he said
I'm gonna make you a lean mean fighting
machine I said I just want to all I want
from you is I want you to teach me to
give I want to get to a point where I'm
given sob fits and he just started belly
laughing really yeah because of course
it'll never happen is that Cooper he
looks like it training with Bradley
Bradley and Brian look at ESPO
couple cuties only Bradley's much
better-looking than me God you ain't
look like [ __ ] I look like a penis here
dude he's a very nice fella I think
Jonah Hill is a hell of an actor he's
Flint home I think he's a sail good yeah
I think he's as good as it gets I really
do I did read for this yeah he will tell
you nuts
all right listen to me listen to me all
[ __ ] aside take it back now take it
back you think you'll be Jonah Hill take
it back just take it back nope on his he
could train for 10 years and I'm not
joking now
well he's blue belt shot the [ __ ] out
under Machado shut up and enjoy Trenton
I like him very much I was younger now
easy I'm a younger man I love that guy
younger I love that guy younger I love
Jonah hell there isn't a sport including
jiu-jitsu I don't care how long don't
I'm feeling rest Lee you know I'm
feeling rest Lee because I'm training
now I told you I already said this to
you on text now he getting his own
shitty you likes you next private got
bumped Danny DeVito's in there I hate to
be stopped raining on my parade
dude I trained now I don't just box but
I roll
now it's gonna sting a little bit what
we can't get you in 2020 Denzel I could
text him right now Watson's book he can
write now time for me nope he and I roll
he loves my stand-up then give a [ __ ]
about you did say that your readers dude
tie me in knots don't say any in what
about you and Bradley Cooper though a
bit Bradley a lot brother oh dear I'm
beating my beat I don't think so really
big kid but you know I've asked Bradley
he'll tell you he doesn't want either
way he doesn't it's okay he's a Philly
kid now I know do any stranger scrappy
you know this you're scrappy yeah yeah
don't don't be when it comes down to it
I'll tell you what when people are
watching go hey Brian let's you can be
them do the most pull-ups hey Brian
let's see him in those push-ups you know
I mean that competition of appeal
watching and then I go 52 year old Brian
becomes 30 year old Brian he beats
everybody you know this oh you're
talking but I'm talking about everyone
well no you beat everyone when your time
your openers on the road the eye-openers
in a row - better than Moloch is did you
beat them Monica kill Moloch no he looks
in shape he's a he's been boxing since
he was 7
ya know they sayin you beat him no no
Moloch no he's good enough when we boxed
- just he just stands right in front of
me and he goes oh they're nice you know
I mean come on well then [ __ ] it as a
whole it's six to one poster boy okay
man it's good it's good
let's get stuff know how we get oh good
it's good roll it's good roll a [ __ ]
my defense skin yeah there dude pretty
good don't like that roll it's not fun
on my throat let's take those tasty on
your throat huh tasty here juicy yeah
you don't have a problem man huh don't
you know if you wanted you could you
didn't offend right no I mean I could if
I we were going crazy if we come to the
mat I'm not gonna go again come to mat
the mat eight six two one I'm gonna do
it here and I'm gonna use all my [ __ ]
this [ __ ] another [ __ ] right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]